the return of TV's number one show
Yellowstone it's back November 13th on
the Paramount Network and expect new
Fallout from all the Dutton family drums
welcome to Yellowstone season five the
problem is how do we top it every year
right
you gotta kind of keep your foot on the
gas
might show us that you guys love the
show
a lot more
fans get 14. it doesn't surprise you
it's very unlikely that it will surprise
an audience Let Me Show the World Who We
Are
what we do Cole Hauser who plays rip
says the first two episodes are
fantastic a big question what will
happen with Kevin Costner's John Dutton
and his adopted son Jamie could you see
him falling in good graces with John
again probably the show would end
My Dysfunctional Family really disturbs
me I'm gonna run everything aren't you
everything the fierceness is is uh is
legitimately ramping up
and based on what Yellowstone co-creator
Taylor Sheridan told us No One Is Safe
this season if you look at everyone as a
chess piece in season five it is
impossible to keep playing the game
without taking chess pieces off the
border and I think there's a sun today
more than 11 million viewers tuned in to
the season 4 finale on the Paramount
Network that's where you can catch the
new season and the highest paid actor on
TV yep Costner brings in a reported 1.3
million dollars an episode it's hard to
get tired of those mountains and rivers
and horses
[Music]
foreign